je vous le disais en titre à tour le
projet de nouvelle hôpital pédiatrique
reporté cinédie il devait intégrer le
site trousseau en 2026 mais la facture a
explosé le vieil hôpital Clocheville a
donc encore de beaux jours devant lui il
est précisions de Léa Turquie
pour le moment l'hôpital pour enfants de
Tours restera bien que le ville une
annonce de Marie-Noëlle Gerin brozard la
directrice du CHU il y a quelques jours
en cause un manque de moyens face à
l'envolée du prix des matériaux de
construction impossible donc d'amortir
le coup du transfert du service
pédiatrie vert trousseau conséquent il
faut remettre aux normes et rénover
l'hôpital Clocheville des travaux à plus
de 10 millions d'euros on a d'abord
besoin de réaliser des travaux de mise
en sécurité incendie et c'est aussi un
site vétuste il y a des endroits de
Clocheville où le parquet craque des
endroits où ils font démonter les portes
des chambres pour passer un lit donc ça
c'est pas c'est pas une situation dont
on ne se on peut se satisfaire en 2023
des locaux vieillissants et donc pas
toujours adapté dans cet hôpital ouvert
depuis 1881 mais il présente tout de
même un avantage de taille une
localisation en plein centre de la ville
alors le report du déménagement vers
trousseau devient une nouvelle pour les
syndicats le déporté en périphérie
aurait pu créer peut-être des problèmes
d'accès pour pour les gens parce que
finalement
centre-ville c'est facile on espère que
avec les 10 millions qui vont être
investis peut-être que la nouvelle
direction
reverra ce projet et laissera
Clocheville là où il est en centre-ville
de Tours ce transfert validé en 2017 et
donc repousser à une date encore un
déterminée alors qu'une nouvelle
direction arrive début mars à la tête du
CHU